correspondent, Sanjay Gupta,
inside a secret lab where the
entire mission is fighting the
threat of fentanyl.
>> Looking at pictures, even if
they're not mine.
Tell a story.
>> He was such a happy baby.
Oh, my god.
So happy all the time.
>> Is it hard to talk about?
>> No, I love talking about him.
I talk about him to anybody that
will listen.
I loved seeing him on a hockey
rink.
I think that was really, really,
his happy place where he could
just sort of be free.
His friends packed up
immediately from schools
wherever they were and came
over.
The family started showing up.
I was just in shock.
We tried.
We were doing cpr and not a
chance.
He was long gone.
I don't say he overdosed.
I say he died from fentanyl
poisoning.
Truthfully at the end of the
day, to me, he was murdered
because he asked for one thing.
They gave him something
different and it took his life.
>> On a single sad night,
November 2nd, Dina's son became
one of the 92,000 fatal
overdoses in 2020 alone.
Much of it driven by fentanyl.
The problem is there's so many
of these drugs that are now on
the street that the Dea had to
set up a secret forensics lab
just to try and keep up.
We're making our way there now.
Scott is deputy assistant
administrator.
You're getting more pills and
more of those pills are coming
back positive for fentanyl?
>> Almost every one of them
comes back positive.
>> In 2019, the Dea seized
roughly 2.2 million pills.
In 2022, 50.6 million pills.
At the beginning of the opioid
epidemic, many of the pills were
authentic.
The majority of the pills being
seized today at the borders, on
the streets, even in schools --
>> Over 99% of what we see are
fake.
>> 99%.
That's mind numb.
And look closely at how sfes
kated the counterfeiters have
become.
>> These are some of the ones
that we will seize.
That have the same M.
>> If you look at what is real
here and the rainbow fentanyl,
they're not even really trying
anymore to disguise this.
This is clearly fake.
But also, if you look at this
800 grams of fentanyl, that
turns into 400 to 500,000
potentially lethal pills.
Think about that.
One bag gives you 400 to 500,000
lethal doses.
It's the message the Dea wants
out there.
One pill can kill.
The days of expert mention are
over and so this sophisticated
lab has to keep up.
Trying to analyze these pills
down to their Moll eck lar
structure, using the equivalent
of an mri machine.
>> We've seen hundreds and
hundred of unique combinations.
One with fentanyl and caffeine,
one with fentanyl and
acetaminophen.
>> How hard is it to keep up
with how much counterfeit stuff
there is out there?
>> The market is constantly
changing so we are trying to do
everything we can from a science
base to keep up with that.
One pill can kill.
It's not worth the chance.
It's not worth your life.
>> It's a message Dina wishes
Matthew could have heard.
So instead, she has made it her
mission to be his voice.
>> As soon as you can start
having these conversations with
your children at an age where